Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week for
my Game of Thrones bonus video I thought it
would be fun to talk about the Blackfyre Rebellion.
Technically there were two of them, but we
can start with the first one and then talk
about the second one.
Quick shoutout to EJ Rivas, you're this week's
book winner.
You get to pick any of Martin's books or short
stories.
I'll message you on your channel for details,
so be sure to check your inbox today.
Hello new people, if you're finding me for
the first time I'm doing weekly game of thrones
videos just for fun while we wait for Season
5 and a weekly Song of Ice and Fire book giveaway.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
I'll pick one random person and announce who
in my next sunday video.
Super simple.
If you've never heard of the Blackfyre name
it's the surname given to Bastards of House
Targaryen.
Like Snow in the North.
Bastard names are given mostly based on the
region you were born in, so there really aren't
any new Blackfyre's being named on the show
right now.
Daenerys is a proven Targaryen, I know there
are a lot of theories about other characters
on the show, but if she ever had a bastard
child, it would be named a Blackfyre.
She's pretty nice, so I don't think she would
ever name any child of hers a bastard.
It's a custom mostly seen in Westeros.
And not all great houses treat their bastards
the same.
Which is part of the reason the first Blackfyre
Rebellion got started.
A good example is Orys Baratheon, he was the
creator of Housed Baratheon.
It's rumored that he was the Bastard son of
Aegon the Conqueror's Father, Aerion Targaryen.
Making him Aegon's half brother.
That's a whole other story, but Orys was like
the Jon Snow of the Targaryen family during
Aegon's time.
So he ended up getting treated like a family
member just like Jon.
Another important example was presented on
the show when Oberyn Martell mentioned that
Dorne treats it's Bastards very favorably.
In Dorne they're all named Sand.
The Blackfyre Rebellion was just one of the
several Targaryen Civil Wars fought over the
succession.
If you've heard about The Dance of The Dragons
or read the Princess and The Queen short story,
you can think of it like that.
That civil war was different in that the war
of succession was between Targaryen children
born inside the line of succession.
Neither one was technically a bastard.
The Blackfyre Rebellion at it's core was Targaryen
Bastards vs Targaryens.
The person responsible for starting it was
King Aegon the Fourth, he lived a little over
a hundred years before the events that are
happening on the show right now.
His character shared a few similarities with
Robert Baratheon, both in their girth and
prolific bastardy.
Aegon, like Robert had a lot of bastards.
He was way more debaucherous than Robert,
he lived during a time when Targaryen power
was unquestioned, there was a lot more money
to blow, so he basically turned the royal
court into a harem.
He had at least 9 mistresses and the joke
was, his modified Targaryen House motto was
"wash her and bring her to my bed".
So you get the idea, he was like a crazier
version of Robert.
Except Robert was at one time, one of the
greatest warriors in Westeros.
Aegon the Fourth was a douche his whole life.
That's why he was dubbed Aegon the unworthy.
On his deathbed he legitimised his oldest
Bastard Son Daemon Blackfyre, knighting him
and giving him the Targaryen sword of succession.
Also called Blackfyre.
It was Aegon the first's Valyrian blade that
was passed down to each new Targaryen King
when they took the Throne.
The Targaryen's being Valyrian, had several
Valyrian swords.
Blackfyre just became the most famous because
it belonged to Aegon the Conqueror.
So weilding it was taken a sign of the right
to rule.
So when Aegon the fourth gave it to his very
young bastard son instead of his supposed
Targaryen son Daeron the Second.
I say supposed, because that son was also
supposedly the son of Aegon's brother.
It was like a Joffrey Lannister Baratheon
situation.
Everybody involved in the situation seems
like they were only having children with people
who they were not married to.
Crazy?
I know.
That's just how they did it in King's Landing
back then I guess.
My theory is that Aegon knew that Daemon wasn't
his true son but did know that Daemon Blackfyre
was, so just out of spite to his wife Naerys
for cheating on him with his brother Aemon,
he named Daemon his successor.
Given his lack of regard for the rules of
court, he was also probably just giving a
giant middle finger to everyone and having
a good laugh before he died.
If something like this were to happen with
the current characters on the show it would
be like Robert Baratheon naming Gendry his
successor when he was dying in season 1 instead
of Joffrey.
I also think that Robert secretly suspected
Joffrey was not his son.
Robert didn't have a sword like Blackfyre,
that was almost more precious than the actual
crown.
He could have given Gendry his warhammer though.
It was supposed to be so large that Ned Stark
couldn't swing it.
And Ned Stark wielded Ice, the two handed
greatsword.
After Aegon the fourth died, it was a long
time before the actual Blackfyre Rebellion
started.
His Targaryen son, Daeron the second succeeded
him without any issues, but over the next
10 years tension between Daemon and Daeron
grew to the point of war.
Daemon was the one that started it, he was
pissed about a few big things.
First was Daeron marrying his sister Daenerys
to a Martell.
She and Daemon were in love, but Daeron wanted
to use her to bring the Martells into the
realm.
Dorne had still not been made part of the
Kingdom.
And Daemon grew more and more resentful about
his bastard status, despite having been legitimized
as a true heir and possessing the famous Blackfyre
sword.
We can probably lay a little blame on his
advisors, but let's be honest.
This was mostly a rebellion started over a
woman.
A lot like Robert's rebellion.
Daemon rallied a lot of the realms bastards
and several of his bastard half brothers,
all sons of Aegon the fourth.
Including Brynden Rivers, the Bloodraven.
He's the
three eyed raven we saw in the season 4 finale.
Although eventually during that conflict Brynden
sided with the crown against Daemon.
The most famous battle during the war was
the Battle of Redgrass Field, the actual field
it took place on didn't have a name.
The battle was named Redgrass because over
Ten Thousand men died during it, including
Daemon and his twin sons Aegon and Aemon.
Before he died, Daemon supposedly met Gwayne
Corbray one of the Kingsguard in a duel on
the battlefield that lasted more than an hour
long.
They were both amazing fighters that each
had Valyrian swords.
Daemon had Blackfyre and Corbray's sword was
named Lady Forlorn.
Daemon won the fight, but his half brother
Brynden Rivers, the bloodraven, who by that
time had switched sides and was fighting for
the crown Killed one of Daemon's sons and
then killed Daemon himself when he went to
pick up his son's body.
Then as Daemon lay dying he passed his sword
Blackfyre to his other son and the Bloodraven
killed him too.
There was a little revenge to be had, one
of Daemon's other bastard half brothers, Bittersteel
fought the Bloodraven and took his eye and
then escaped to the east to form the Golden
Company.
Remember, Ser Davos mentioned them during
season 4.
We might get to see them on the show at some
point.
That battle was the end of the first Blackfyre
Rebellion, even though Bittersteel escaped
with a few other survivors and the famous
Blackfyre Sword.
On his deathbed he commanded his successors
to boil his skull, dip it in gold and carry
it before them as they later tried to re-take
westeros with a new army.
That became the second Blackfyre Rebellion.
And it's one of the reasons their banner has
skulls on it, it's the golden skulls of former
commanders.
Their motto is "our word is good as gold"
because they've supposedly never broken a
contract.
The Golden Company is really interesting so
unless you guys want me to do something else,
I think I'll do a bonus video for them next.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
That video will post next Sunday, tonight
there's some really cool stuff happening.
We're getting new Walking Dead Season 5 footage.
I'm going to be doing a special video for
it.
You can click here to get it, I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it.
And click here to learn all about my White
Walker Prophecy Theories.
I had a lot of fun making that video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight,
high fives!